>> LOOK, THERE IS NO FEDERAL
SOLUTION.
THIS GETS SOLVED AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
I’M LOOK AT GOVERNOR SUNUNU ON
THE BOARD HERE.
HE TALKS ABOUT THAT A LOT.
AND IT ULTIMATELY GETS DOWN TO
WHERE THE RUBBER MEETS THE ROAD,
AND THAT’S WHERE THE PATIENT IS
IN NEED OF HELP OR PREVENTING
THE NEED FOR HELP.
JASON: THAT’S PRESIDENT BIDEN
LAST WEEK SAYING THE SOLUTION TO
FIGHTING COVID-19 RESIDES AT THE
STATE LEVEL DESPITE HIS PROMISE
TO, QUOTE, SHUT DOWN THE VIRUS
DURING THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
THIS COMES AS NEW CASES ARE
RAPIDLY SURGING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY DUE TO THE OMICRON
VARIANT.
NEW YORK SET A RECORD YESTERDAY
FOR ITS HIGHEST EVER SINGLE-DAY
TOTAL OF NEW CASES WITH OVER
85,000.
FLORIDA IS ALSO SEEING RECORD
HIGH CASES.
MEANWHILE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROMISED TO
DELIVER 500 MILLION AT-HOME
TESTS SOON DESPITE THE
ADMINISTRATION REPORTEDLY
REJECTING A PROPOSAL FROM
TESTING EXPERTS IN OCTOBER TO
RAMP UP PRODUCTION BEFORE THE
HOLIDAYS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DENIED THAT
REPORT.
FOR MORE ON THIS, LET’S BRING IN
NEW YORK CONGRESSWOMAN NICOLE
MALL YA TACK MALLIOTAKIS, MEMBER
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE COMMITTEE.
CONGRESS MONTH, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US ON "SUNDAY
MORNING FUTURES."
THE PRESIDENT PROMISED TO SHUT
IT DOWN IN JULY, NOW HE’S SAYING
IT’S REALLY UP TO THE STATES.
HE SAID HE HAD A PLAN, BUT I
CAN’T TELL IF THE GUY HAS A
PLAN.
IF HE DOES, IT’S A REALLY GOOD
SECRET THERE.
>> HAPPY NEW YEAR, JASON.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
THE REALITY IS THE PRESIDENT
MADE A LOT OF PROMISES DURING
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
WE’RE NOT SEEING IT COME TO
FRUITION NOW.
IN FACT, HE WAS SO CRITICAL OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP, YET WE’VE HAD
MORE DEATHS IN 2021 UNDER
PRESIDENT BIDEN, AND HE HAD THE
BENEFIT OF THE VACCINATION WHICH
WE KNOW REDUCES THE SYMPTOMS
THAT SOMEBODY EXPERIENCES IF
THEY TEST POSITIVE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM A STATE
LIKE NEW YORK WHERE WE HAVE
ONE-PARTY RULE AND WE SEE
RESTRICTIONS AND MANDATES AND
PEOPLE BEING FIRED, LOSING THEIR
LIVELIHOOD IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
VACCINATE, THESE RESTRICTIONS
HAVE DONE NOTHING TO REALLY
REDUCE THE LEVEL OF THESE
POSITIVE CASES.
AS YOU SAID EARLIER, WE’RE
SEEING RECORD POSITIVE CASES
ONCE AGAIN, AND I BELIEVE IT’S
TIME THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION
FOCUS ON THERAPEUTICS, FOCUS ON
TREATMENTS.
AND I’VE BEEN PUSHING FOR THAT
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS, IS THAT
THIS VIRUS IS HERE TO STAY.
VARIOUS VARIANTS, VARIOUS FORMS,
WE NEED TO LEARN TO LIVE WITH
IT.
AND THE BEST WE’RE GOING TO DO,
BOTH VACCINATING PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO BE VACCINATED AND MAKING SURE
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO IT, BUT ALSO
UNSURING WE HAVE THE
THERAPEUTICS AND THE TREATMENT
TO TREAT PEOPLE WHO DO END UP
GETTING SICK EVEN DESPITE THE
VACCINATION.
JASON: YEAH, I KIND OF LIKE WHAT
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN SAID.
HE SAID IF PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
PLAN IS WORKING, HOW CAN IT’S
NOT WORKING?
IT JUST BEGS THE QUESTION.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE NOW THAT ARE
SAYING THE WRONG WAY TO TRACK
THIS IS BY THE NUMBER OF NEW
CASES.
HOW CONVENIENT FOR THE NEW
PRESIDENT TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ON
THIS ROLE.
BUT IT ALSO STRIKES ME,
CONGRESSWOMAN, THAT IT IS NOT A
VERY TARGETED APPROACH TO JUST
PLANT -- BLANKETLY SEND OUT
TESTS.
WHY NOT TARGET THOSE THAT ARE
THE MOST VULNERABLE, THE PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY ARE SHOWING
SYMPTOMS?
I JUST DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY THAT
ISN’T THE PREVAILING THOUGHT
THERE IN WASHINGTON D.C.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
VERY REACTIVE.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THE
TREATMENTS AND THERAPEUTICS,
THEY WANT TO FOCUS ON MORE
MANDATES.
AND YOU’RE RIGHT, IF HE BELIEVES
NOW THIS SHOULD BE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATES,
WHY IS HE CONTINUING TO TRY TO
ENFORCE THIS MANDATE ON EVERY
BUSINESS ACROSS AMERICA, 82
MILLION AMERICANS AFFECTED BY IT
WHO WILL LOSE THEIR LIVELIHOODS
AS A RESULT?
THAT IS WHY I AND 180 COLLEAGUES
OF MINE IN CONGRESS HAVE FILED
AN AMICUS BRIEF WITH THE SUPREME
COURT WHICH WILL BE HEARING THAT
CASE -- AT LEAST FOR THE STAY --
ON JANUARY 7TH.
JASON: WELL, GOOD LUCK WITH
THAT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT CRIME
BECAUSE THERE IS AN INTERSECTION
HERE, AND I KNOW YOU’RE KEEN ON
CRIME AND BEING ABLE TO FIGHT
CRIME.
FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE AN OPEN
BORDER.
IT’S AS POROUS AS IT CAN BE.
IT JUST FLOWS.
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS WITH WHO
KNOWS WHAT WHETHER IT’S OMICRON
OR, YOU KNOW, THE VIRUS OR DRUGS
OR WHAT NOT.
BUT THEN YOU ALSO HAVE THIS
CRIME SURGE THAT’S HAPPENING IN
THESE DEMOCRATIC CITIES
INCLUDING NEW YORK CITY WHICH IS
CLOSE TO YOU.
>> YEAH.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I DID AS
A MEMBER OF CONGRESS WAS VISIT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER TO EXPOSE
WHAT WAS GOING ON THERE.
AND BASICALLY, PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS ALLOWED DRUG CARTELS TO RUN
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE ARE SEEING RECORD INDIVIDUALS
BEING SMUGGLED OVER THE BORDER,
BUT ALSO WE’RE SEEING DRUGS,
FENTANYL, AS YOU KNOW, IS NOW
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN A
NEW REPORT AMONG 18 TO
45-YEAR-OLDS.
SO YOU CAN TALK ABOUT COVID, BUT
AMONG THAT AGE GROUP IT IS
FENTANYL X. THAT STUFF IS
POURING OVER OUR BORDER.
THE DRUG CARTELS ARE MAKING
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A MONTH JUST DOING THAT.
AND SO WE NEED TO SECURE OUR
BORDER.
IT IS SHOCKING TO ME THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN CONTINUES TO
PUSH THE SUPREME COURT TO ALLOW
HIM TO REPEAL ONCE AGAIN THE
REMAIN -- HE DOESN’T WANT TO
COMPLY WITH IT DESPITE THE FACT
THAT IT WAS EFFECTIVE IN KEEPING
PEOPLE IN MEXICO UNTIL THEIR
ASYLUM CASES CAN BE HEARD AND
THEY’RE PROPERLY VETTED.
NOW, LOCALLY WE HAVE -- NEW YORK
CITY, OF COURSE, SADLY, A
SANCTUARY CITY.
WE CONTINUE TO PROTECT THOSE
HERE ILLEGALLY COMMITTING
CRIMES.
IN FACT, SOMEONE WHO WAS
ARRESTED, A MEXICAN NATIONAL WHO
WAS COMMITTING DRUG TRAFFICKING
ALLEGEDLY, FENTANYL HERE IN NEW
YORK CITY, WAS RELEASED BY A
JUDGE BACK ONTO THE STREETS.
SO WE NEED OUR MAYOR TO APPOINT
GOOD JUDGES TO THE BENCH, NUMBER
ONE.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO INSURE THAT
HE FIGHTS FOR CHANGES TO THE
DISASTROUS BAIL REFORM IN ALBANY
THAT HAS LED TO INDIVIDUALS
CONSTANTLY BEING PUT BACK ON THE
STREETS DESPITE HAVING DOZEN,
TWO DOZEN, THREE DOZEN PRIOR
ARRESTS AND CONVICTIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY IN NEW YORK CITY
IN 2021, WE SAW FIVE, NEARLY 500
MURDERS WHICH IS THE MOST WE’VE
SEEN IN A DECADE HERE IN NEW
YORK CITY.
AND CATEGORIES OF CRIME,
EVERYTHING FROM SHOOTINGS TO
RAPES TO ROBBERIES TO CAR THEFTS
HAVE ALL SKYROCKETED.
IN FACT, INTERESTING TO KNOW
THAT ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ’S
HOME BOROUGH OF THE BRONX IS
WHERE A THIRD OF THE SHOOTINGS
TOOK PLACE IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
SHE IS ONE OF THE LEADING
ADVOCATE CANS OF THE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT.
JASON: YEAH.
THIS IDEA OF THE BAIL REFORM
GETTING THESE PEOPLE BACK OUT ON
THE STREET AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE, I THINK, IS NOT THE
RIGHT WAY TO SOLVE THIS.
AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE PROSECUTORS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES.
IN LOS ANGELES WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY, GASCON, IT’S AS
RAMPANT IF AS CAN POSSIBLY BE.
AND THE SOLUTION ENDS UP BEING
JUST ABSOLUTELY HORRENDOUS IN
TERMS OF ITS, OF ITS
CONSEQUENCES.
I WANT TO TURN NOW, LET’S LISTEN
TO GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
HE WAS INTERVIEWED BY MARIA BART
BARTIROMO -- BART ROMO, AND I
WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO THIS AND
GIVE ME YOUR REACTION TO IT.
>> THE CARTELS ARE ADVERTISING
ON TIKTOK TO GET DRIVERS TO
ASSIST IN THEM MOVING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AROUND THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
IT’S AN ISSUE THAT THE TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY IS
WORKING TO CRACK DOWN UPON, BUT
IT SHOWS THE EXTENT TO WHICH
TEXAS LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
HAVE TO STEP UP AND DOLE WITH
THE CHALLENGES -- DEAL WITH THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE CREATED BY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IMPORTING ILLEGAL ACTIVITY INTO
OUR COUNTRY AND INTO OUR STATE.
MARIA: YEAH.
JASON: NOW, WE ONLY HAVE A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME HERE, BUT I THINK
WE’VE BEEN -- YOU’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS, THE CRIME,
COVID, FENTANYL, OPEN BORDERS.
THEY ALL KIND OF MESH TOGETHER.
BUT YOU’RE LEFT WITH STATES LIKE
TEXAS WHERE GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS
GOT HIS HANDS FULL, AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT DOING ITS
JOB.
WHAT CAN YOU DO IN CONGRESS TO
GET THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ACTUALLY ENFORCE THE LAWS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY ON THE BOOKS?
>> WELL, AS YOU KNOW, THOSE
STATES HAVE TAKEN THEIR FIGHT TO
COURT, WHICH IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO, AND THAT IS WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN FORCED
TO REINSTATE THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO.
THE SAD THING IS THAT NOW
THEY’RE EVEN FIGHTING TO TRY TO
GET THE SUPREME COURT TO REVISIT
IT AGAIN SO THEY CAN NO LONGER
ENFORCE THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY THAT WAS CLEAR AND WAS
WORKING.
THE REALITY IS, AND THIS IS WHAT
I ASKED ON THE FLOOR TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WHOSE SIDE
ARE YOU ON?
ARE YOU ON THE SIDE OF THE DRUG
CARTELS, OR ARE YOU ON THE SIDE
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
WHEN YOU SEE THOSE NUMBERS OUT
OF 18 TO 45-YEAR-OLD WITHS THAT
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IS
FENTANYL, YOU KNOW IT’S
STREAMING OVER THE BORDER, YOU
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO DO
SOMETHING.
JASON: YEAH.
>> AND THE FACT THAT THEY GO OUT
OF THEIR WAY TO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THIS ILLEGAL MIGRATION
WHICH, BY THE WAY, THIS YEAR
WILL TOTAL MORE THAN THE
POPULATION OF THE PRESIDENT’S
HOME STATE OF DELAWARE AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT’S HOME CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO COMBINED.
SO WE HAVE LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD PERMANENTLY PUT REMAIN IN
MEXICO INTO LAW, BUT WE NEED TO
TAKE BACK THE HOUSE IN ORDER TO
DO IT BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI WILL
NEVER ALLOW IT TO THE FLOOR
UNDER THIS CONGRESS.
JASON: YEAH.
THERE ARE 23 RETIRING DEMOCRATS
ON SLATE HERE, AND REPUBLICANS
BETTER COME UP WITH A WAY TO NOT
JUST BE THE PARTY OF NO, BUT
JUST -- AND SAY, HEY, THIS IS
OUR AGENDA, THIS IS WHAT WE
WOULD DO, THIS -- IF YOU PUT US
IN CHARGE -- IS WHAT WE WILL
ACTUALLY DO.
ALL OF THESE RETIREMENTS, THIS
WAVE OF RETIREMENTS CREATES A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY, AND
REPUBLICANS, WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO HAVE YOU BACK ON TO TALK MORE
ABOUT THEIR AGENDA AND WHAT THEY
CAN DO.
FOR NOW LET’S JUST SAY HAPPY NEW
YEAR AND THANK YOU.
CONGRESSWOMAN MALLIOTAKIS, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US HERE ON